so everyone is freaking out and asking
where the heck is the Avengers for
trailer what is the official title of
Avengers 4 just give it to us already
[Music]
I know everybody including myself is
growing very very impatient and things
started to get a little scary because
Disney and Marvel studio started talking
about doing marketing that nobody has
ever done before doing it in a different
way that they've never done before so
everybody starts talking about this and
all of a sudden there's a rumor going
around that we might not even get a
trailer at all for Avengers 4 so
everybody starts freaking out some
people start saying well they don't even
need to drop a trailer because the hype
is already big enough for everybody to
go see it anyways and I got a lot of
messages asking me if we're actually
going to see a trailer for Avengers 4
well of course Disney and Marvel never
said that we're not going to get a
trailer this was just speculation but
thankfully Marvel's co-president luis de
espacio cleared things up for us when
the first teaser trailer for The Lion
King came out one fan took to Twitter
and asked Luis if Avengers infinity war
would be getting the same treatment in
the next week or two basically saying
are we getting the Avengers 4 trailer in
the next week or two in which Marvel's
co-president replied are you trying to
trick me into telling you when a four
teaser trailer will be released I know
the date and want to reveal it but I
can't be patient although it doesn't
answer when the trailer is going to come
out it does confirm that there will in
fact be a trailer so everybody can rest
easy now about the trailer release date
I don't think anybody truly knows many
thought it could come out tonight or
tomorrow because the Russo brothers are
doing their infinity war screening with
a QA after but this is not confirmed one
thing that we do know is that it should
come before December 5th the reasoning
behind this is twofold one Marvel always
puts out the trailers before they put
out the prelude and two the prelude will
probably reveal the title of the next
movie so they probably would do the
trailer before December 5th again it's
not confirmed but they should do it and
also the Russo brothers screening and QA
tonight should hopefully give us more
details even if they don't show the
trailer tonight you know that the QA is
going to be a lot about Avengers 4 and
you know somebody's going to ask about
the trailer and the release date and the
title as I mentioned before I have a
friend who will be attending and he'll
be tweeting giving updates and texting
with updates as well throughout the
whole entire event so be sure to follow
him on Twitter he'll be live tweeting
throughout the event when he can and
he'll also be texting me and updating me
as well so be sure to follow him on
Twitter at I'm a film editor and be sure
to follow me as well at the CW official
I'll put those both in the description
down below so hopefully tonight we get
some reveals about Avengers 4 and if not
hopefully we get closer to it let me
know when you think we're going to get
the trailer and let me know what you
think the title is going to be and if
you'd like to enter my giveaway for a
chance to win a copy of infinity war the
art of the movie art book a copy of
infinity war Deadpool 2 or ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray as well as some
special edition posters all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always I super appreciate you all
watching wolf wolf
[Music]
you
[Music]